venerdì ragazzi di questo nuovo io sono
fa vj ed era da una vita che non faceva
un video sui rockets league
ho deciso di ritornare un po in bellezza
perché oggi in bruttezza perché oggi
sono con ciccio ciao perfetto ci ha
stordito tutti quanti a lui ha invitato
un suo amico che è uno dei campioni del
mondo dio che ti italiano stiamo fuchs
il lo conoscevo già ed è uno dei
giocatori al mondo più forti di
rocchetti ed ettore mondiale lui ha
inventato la prima per lui lo sa meglio
prezzi tornano se si sentono dalla
ciccio ci ha fatto la cortesia di fare
da tramite oggi perché io e ciccio
giocheremo contro cook si gli faremo un
coup sir così io con le battute ci fa
veramente vomitare
nella serata sei un ispirazione per me
la cosa veramente hai una macchina molto
carina e allora ascoltami caro io volevo
fare un due contro uno
se non ti senti di perdere per carità ci
andremo piano io e ciccio diglielo che
ci andiamo piano abbracciamo un amoroso
bravo velico sylvian allora ciccio devi
essere pronto nel caso siamo 10 a 0 a
fargli fare due tre gol viene dai
partigiani
va bene nella prossima faremo di meglio
però non è andata male generica possiamo
vincere perché nevica la neve la neve la
neve la neve il suo nemico
la neve è nostro ha mica ce la possiamo
fare vai sulla palla ciccio sulla palla
sulla palla la palla non di neve la
parola cioè la palla ci c'era giocavo
per carla carla demonio a questo l'ha
inventato to di tiro vero è vero come si
chiamava il tuo esatto il piuss e l'ho
fatto l'ho fatto al mondiale è stato
molto soddisfacente progressivo ripari
io però tiro è quella finta di prima la
grata tu vada una finta di circolo era
quella a questo era infatti già i pinci
che balla la mia parte però dai che
forse un 1 a 0
non ci credo ma perché c'ho creduto
gradutoria ciccio dai che un 10 voglio
10 una volta per noi una gara dove trova
bellissimo effetto per svelare siamo più
carica adesso porco demonio si no ciao
ho creduto
porca vacca va bene rimette in mezzo al
20 di mezzo li metti la faccia su
demonio morto kira vabbè da me la bella
vai vai vai sulla palla ce la farà ci
credo ci credo due minuti senza prendere
gol incredibile vantaggio perfetto era
buono buono buono vai ciccio che ci
siamo scaldati vai scherzavo scherzavo
la tolgo dai no guarda ero lì
maledizione non sono un fatto forse è
colpa mia è decisamente col fattura da
che parte stai scusami non è che perché
vita allo stesso modo di giocare per lui
guarda
o no l'unica possibilità che avevo
disegnare tutto il video è impossibile
ma vabbè togli la ma porca vacca
se ti prego per un 2 a 0 è prima eravamo
già 80 se per caso entra in porta una
volta gesù mi vuole bene
incredibile ci ho messo una vita a
segnare va bene ha fatto il governo a un
campione del mondo i mondiali sono un
passo era fatto sono più hai fatto sui
mondiali hanno mai mai mai mai
va bene sicuramente ha fatto fare questo
2 2
beh non può sognare sul muro ok come sto
scherzando e stava entrando cimetti
difficoltà 20 difficoltà mettiti cota
non a me lui ma no dai cc ma per favore
quello che ha pagato ma vai milano cosa
vuoi da me la forte da guardalo guardalo
no vabbè ragazzi nella prossima a messi
d'accordo prima cosa fai
faccio io lascia faccio io non è vero
tocca la collo da taglio
ma cosa incredibile dirà di noi io
scherzavo di ore il tuo piccolo ometto
non è
del pid giordana beh non ha senso perché
tante altre tre ragazze 33 33 con tutti
e tre sono vai vai vai tira possiamo
vincerla se segniamo e per qualche
strano motivo vinciamo nell'altra porta
ciccio lo specifico ma che tiro era che
c'azzecca orribile ti prego non
prendiamo così perfetto 16 secondi dalla
fine voglio morire adesso voglio morire
in questo non è guardato guarda cosa ho
fatto io è attirato guarda io guarda è
appreso il tentativo dai giudici la
sopresa alla fine madonna non so come ho
fatto ha presentato la totalmente presa
mega allargato però 4 3 3 gg g20 è un
signor risultato secondo me per quanto
abbiamo fatto comunque schifo cosa ho
detto mario bravo quello che sarebbe
inutile farlo che dice è la mappa è
quella giusta
se lo mettiamo vorrei essere in
vantaggio almeno per un secondo
poi possiamo perdere vai ciccio vai vai
ciccio perfetto sul muro poi fatale di
tono molto bene cioè un po per scontato
se laggiù strasse 15 andato subito sulla
palla va in mezzo tira fai qualcosa
nella tua vita
intanto non si impegnarono per mettetele
in mezzo 00 si è nei sogni porta tira ma
il babel e non si stacca dal muro con
tettoia toglie talia parco demonio ci
avevo creduto proprio fattore va bene ti
capisco non un cielo a contenere credito
by possiamo farcela toglie la solida
forte e togli la forte toglie la bravo
occhio clinico che rientra che tuccella
bravo ok tirerei chiave prefetto non ci
credo non ci credo perché mai fatto una
cosa che debbano la farà mai l'ha fatta
e ci sei riuscito pure quando eri così
ha detto tanto non lo fa non ce la farà
mai invece l'aipa bravissimo dai che
siamo nel club degli dei
no ho sbagliato poteva cagata
incredibile però non hanno assegnato
ecco uno detto
io non so perché non so lui da quando
viene quando cosa fa nava con sbagliato
io l'ho tirata indietro fortissimo gesù
bravissimo
oh mio dio mio dio mio sì una sega
perché tira di nuovo geni che consentì
stai fermo però non fare gol
senti che se volete ti stai fermo e
bellissimo parlano figure l'incontro
freezer lavare anche pensa stiamo qui
l'incontro tra goku forse aspetta bravo
ciccio ho creduto in te stavolta dai
come come come mamma pausa gesù cristo
sarebbe di che sarebbe di ciccio questa
sarebbe italiano letteralmente mamma
falsi braccianti siciliani in questo no
da quelle angolazioni non vedo mai
segnare nessuno vi dico va bene vado va
invece ad angolare anche lì va beh c'è
anche la la difesa devi stare attento
cité qualcuno importa fisso dell'estate
si sappia stare proprio maria che già
siamo 381 vince ma penso proprio di si
guarda senti questo video non allora io
posso spiegare no non puoi spiegare
niente ci si aspetta testa contro carla
non abbiamo fregato
è già stata tutta il timer cesano
terapeutici di chi si mette nei guai tra
l'altro zio tra questo e su persone ma
12 miliardi di gioco sono un pò tante
aree dai l'ultima è vai ciccio almeno in
vantaggio almeno in vantaggio all'inizio
ma rileva ci sto ci sto blog alla
guardati i ragazzi queste erano le
partite contro cook sir che abbiamo
fatto vincere perché si fa allora io vi
insegnerò a quando una persona gioca da
sola la si fa a vincere perché è in
maggioranza numerica si dà il vantaggio
all'avversario esca fair play fair play
fate il fair play per ora viene sempre
100 ragazzi come al solito servizio è
piaciuto al documento è un mi piace
anche vari social che come noi ha dato
nell'iscrizione ringrazio cook sir per
la disponibilità e ciccio per la
simpatia e il talento e io per nessuno
queste cose commentato ceriano questo
video da ragazzi
[Musica]